welcome to the Thursday Thursday October
the 31st 2019 session in our series on
edge computing I'm Richard Asher I
direct the u.s. agent Technology
Management Center at Stanford and we're
very happy to be presenting this program
that if you're watching on video you're
singing that we're on the Stanford
YouTube channel so previous sessions in
this series are already available on
YouTube check our website Asia dot
stanford.edu in order to find them
that's probably the easiest way to find
all the sessions in this series which
started back on September the 26 so we
are an industry funded Research Center
at Stanford and if you're here in person
please plan to stay after the formal
session is over have some refreshments
outside with us with our speakers in me
and you'll see the member companies of
the u.s. Aegis Technology Management
Center there so for today's session
before I introduce today's session we do
not have a program next week November 7
our next program will be on November the
14th when we have a special video
conferenced presentation coming in live
and interactive from Tokyo Japan which
is where I'll be two weeks from today
but for today we are going to talk about
tiny ml which is an operating kind of
framework to use for edge computing any
kind of artificial intelligence but it's
especially appropriate for edge devices
with us on my left is dr. Evgeny Gustav
who is a senior director of engineering
for a Qualcomm Research and on my right
is Pete worden who is a staff of search
engineer with Google so we're going to
start off with F Guinea Evgeny is
leading the hardware research and
development organization in Silicon
Valley
he and I have known each other
for a number of years because he was
sponsoring a lot of research through the
Center for integrated systems which then
became the system X Alliance at Stanford
and you know we've appreciated your work
in our programs in your mentoring of our
PhD students for a long time he's
responsible for developing
ultra-low-power embedded computing
platform and also always-on machine
vision AI technologies he's been with
Qualcomm technologies since 2005 after
joining from the IBM TJ Watson Research
Center he's held academic professor
appointments and Rutgers and also
Hiroshima University in 1997 wow I
didn't know that and he's also got an MS
and Applied Physics and a PhD in
solid-state physics
he's edited over 24 books and published
163 papers and he's an inventor on over
60 issued and filed patents so I'll
introduce Pete when it's Pete's turn to
speak first of all I'm going to ask if
give me two talk you've got your slides
up and Peter and I will get to go listen
we'll see you in a minute thanks thanks
very much for to me yeah thank you
Richard for the introduction is the mic
on can you guys hear me yeah okay so my
name is Jani Joseph again I'm from
Qualcomm I research a Yeti search we are
based here in the Bay Area and today we
will be talking about tiny ml by the way
my background is more on a systems
hardware side of things less so on the
software PD another way is more software
wear so on the on the type of things so
you can see we're very complementary
we've been partnering on tiny ml for
quite a while when we started this
discussion about a year ago we thought
that would be like a topic maybe for a
couple of dozen of people we had our
first time in three years a few months
later it was over hundred people about
200 people and now the tiny male
community professional community is over
thousand people you can see it's growing
very very fast and there are reasons for
this and hope
we are going to share this excitement
with you today why we are so excited
about this area because it's quite
interesting for for three reasons one
it's very challenging from the
technological and science perspective
there is a lot of thinking a lot of
innovations has to go there to make it
happen second there are tons of
applications there like enormous
applications we are going to show some
examples to you I have some examples
pictures of examples to share in his
presentations just tons of examples it's
mind-blowing what you can do this tiny
mail and number three just simply fun to
do this kind of things and it's kind of
be part of this community so this is the
four things I'd like to address in my
presentation and this is going to be
very very running of high-level
introductory because the idea for today
is really to have more Q&A and panel
discussion so this is just to introduce
the topic and make make the key points
I'll talk probably for about 10 to 15
minutes and then Pete will do the same
from his angle and then you'll have a
Q&A and panel discussion here so what
I'll try to do in in the next 10-15
minutes is needed to do four things one
is to define what tiny mail is second is
to tell you why we are so excited about
tiny mail number three is to give you
some ideas how to make tiny mail type of
devices in systems work what the key
ingredients they are and what are the
key applications they are some of the
key applications are and number three
you're going to see the one type of
question so let's start so we all live
in a physical world we enjoy living in
physical world and by the way this is a
picture of my dog hiding hiding from me
so we're very very physical very very
analog world so at the same time yet we
live in increasingly in a very stressful
digital world so how these two are
connected so when people think about
digital world first thing that comes to
mind is clouded my cloud is everything
but in reality I think people
underestimate the importance of this
tiny thing so this tiny thing is called
transducer so what the thing does
and this thing is composed of the sensor
analog to digital converter and some
kind of microprocessor
so what do you think does it takes an
analogue signal from the ambient and
this analog signal can be anything can
be audio can be temperature can the
pressure can be a video can be anything
pressure chemical signals and then it
converts it into the digital signal and
then a microprocessor does some
pre-processing there and then you have
tons of zeros and ones digital
informations going to the next next
level and the next level typically it's
in the H type of device or cloud type of
device works fine you see a lot of
applications see a lot of papers but
this approach has three fundamental or
four fundamental problems number one
energy energy efficiency is very low for
this type of systems because we are
transferring a lot of data because the
end goal of the of the whole exercise
here is really to get some meaningful
information meaningful data not just
send the data back and forth and this
type of system today is extremely
inefficient because we are sending a lot
of data it takes lot of benefits in the
internet and and so on second issue that
is becoming more and more critical is
privacy because you're sending data over
who knows where and you don't know what
is going to happen to this data that's
it's a varied concern number three to be
able to send this data up and down it
takes time so you have some latency and
people are increasingly impatient to to
few seconds of delay or even
milliseconds of the way it has to be
instantaneous you push a button and you
get your Amazon box like next next
minute so so so that's that's kind of
where we are going so I think latency is
important and number four is reliability
what happens if your network is down
then you're stuck you cannot send the
data to the to the cloud you're stuck so
that's a problem and that's what tiny
mail souls so basically what we do with
tiny mail and the tiny American see see
it's right here so the way we define
tiny mail is the technology or set of
technologies that enables intelligence
happening at the very edge at the very
edge of the physical world at the edge
between physical and end them and in the
digital world and that type of approach
solves all these four problems first
energy because we do processing
right there so it consumes much less
energies it's much much more hundreds of
orders of magnitude more more efficient
than the traditional approach because
all the process happens at this boundary
of the physical world we are not sending
data anywhere so by design by definition
this is a privacy type of design so we
are not facing there's any type of
issues because whoever produces the data
sense of device or whatever one
basically owns this data and just sends
metadata out like the device failed I
see people here its type of thing number
three obviously because we are not
sending data back and forth there are no
latency problems and no there are very
problems yep that's what tiny mail is
but at the same time to realize this
vision in practice in practical system
it's not so trivial because this type of
system are severely constrained from
from all kind of angles first of all
this type of devices cannot afford big
batteries at most you have tens to
hundreds milliamps our type of batteries
ideally would like the devices to run on
energy scavenging with no battery and
there are some applications some
examples of this do not have too much
processing power you have some micro
control type of processor they're quite
powerful today compared to to few years
back but it's still you running them a
chance maybe hundreds of megahertz at
most without any acceleration we'll talk
about acceleration you can do some
special tricks to make this Hardware
more efficient but in general kind of
you can strain the memory is a big deal
because memories silicon area you don't
really have too much memory to run
artificial intelligence at the edge
machine learning at ADH and typical
machine learning models they can take
today megabytes of memory so in this
type of systems
definitely less than one megabyte and
quite often wasn't hungry
kilobytes so you really software people
really constrain what you can do because
software takes some memory then you need
applications model all your networks so
that's not challenging and obviously if
they take in this massive deployment of
this type of devices at the edge of the
physical and digital world the cost has
to be
so those are also the constraints we
have to operate within these boundary
conditions so based on this there is no
like hard definition what dynamo is by
the way we kind of divide defining
broadly it's a set of machine learning
architectures techniques tools and
approaches that help in and capable of
doing machine learning operations at the
very edge for variety of sensing
modalities can do vision audio motion
chemical and so on by the key here and
we've been debating this a kind of this
number in the tiny mill community for a
while what is the boundary between tiny
not tiny and kind of today we define
tiny ml is this type of system that
operated milli watt power or below
that's pretty pretty challenging target
because typically if you're on machine
learning today on service it's tens or
hundreds of what's kind of each type of
devices maybe what type of you what type
of thing but get into this submitter
what which a thousand X less than the
current state-of-the-art that's that's
not not the trivial task and obviously
for this the boundary between the
physical world and the and the digital
world the the battery parity is a big
deal so what we are doing this
the explanation is shown here so I think
we are increasingly believing that data
is a new oil or new electricity English
this was invented here sense but I think
that oil data is new oil by engineer and
his team but if you look where the data
is cloud I think it's about one percent
of the data is in the cloud and people
develop a lot of businesses and business
models based on just this one percentage
of data at the edge type of devices
where people run optimized CN n on
optimize associates then you have about
four or five percent of the data and
this data comes most different pictures
people doing likes/dislikes type of
things
all this gaiden and into the systems and
people do machine learning on those GPS
data but 95 percent of the data is in
the physical world so 95 percent of the
war
we are not really touching today isn't a
physical world
so what tiny mail allows tiny mail
allows to extract this oil this money
from the physical world and do something
useful that without it so that's
basically the main motivation here and
that's what that's what you see in the
physical world you have a variety of
sensing modalities CMOS cameras infrared
cameras inertia units motion units audio
environmental sensors temperatures
optical chemical a variety of sensors
that people can use and get some some
meaningful information to do something
either for business or for the good or
Society began the motivation here for
the tiny male and that's why we are so
excited about this there is just tons of
data available there we just need to
develop these tools and techniques to
extract this data and give it back to
people application wise as I said
earlier it's really mind blowing type of
thing because a tiny male can be used
basically everywhere so we see the
medical application smart cities
industrial IOT wearables cameras drones
any kind of device appliances any
wearables any type of device that is
constrained with power and form factor
but any type of device that deals with
physical world again we define an email
where we get the information and you do
intelligence right there without sending
it to to the cloud so it's basically
everywhere so that's the message there
and then you can think what is the
market size of tiny mail and in general
kind of market reports for this type of
technologies are not reliable they just
more like a guidance so we work with
this company in the San Diego area
design and intelligence they done some
research for us and you can see we are
talking about billions of dollars in the
next five years close to maybe hundred
billion just that what tiny ml can bring
back to businesses and Bakey verticals
there is a logistics mercied is
infrastructure for for manufacturing
automation retail this big big verticals
but this is not all of them again there
are the medical applications there are
wellness type of applications smart home
type of applications it's really a big
market that that's the message here
okay so moving on to the to the hull
question I think what we learned as a
community and the company to build a
fish and tiny mail systems you really
need to look at system holistically and
software hardware algorithm everything
need need need needs to be connected and
everything has to be optimized you
cannot kind of have one thing that is
open and lost defined and then you have
other pieces that are optimal so it
really has to be holistic and it has to
be optimal and this one is just to show
that my statement my claim here is that
tiny email is good enough now so if you
look at the hard way piece so we see a
lot of new hardware accelerators come in
there to improve this performance of
standard CPUs or several companies big
companies startup companies working in
this area and there is quite a bit of
progress there again to the poor and at
this type of technologies more than good
enough now on the algorithm side and
Pete is going to talk about this again
typical cloud-based email models take
tens hundreds of megabytes because they
have huge big big networks very
efficient in terms of accuracy but again
they take a lot of lot of memory a lot
of weights a lot of layers so I think
the challenge here and there is also
quite a bit of progress how do you make
this network smaller and still working
working very very well that's again the
tiny mail challenge and again Pete is
going to talk about this and I'll show
some examples and on the software and
application side we already see some
applications come in and happen in this
space to destory a again tiny mail is
good enough what do we see coming in the
near future we see a lot of progress
happening in this area so on the
hardware side there are a lot of good
work and research happening both on an
academic side and the industry side in
some areas on their computer memory
analog computers you know more for
computing and so on so this is how to
extend current digital architectures to
the next level that will be the next
wave on the hardware side on the
algorithm side I do believe and we
already some examples this
it's kilobytes of memory models will
become chance or maybe even less in fact
what we do in Qualcomm our models today
and for some applications rather than
tell kilobytes of memory for vision what
your applications even less so that kind
of becomes but you do it it's not the
trivial tasks people will be developing
new networks you know greetings and I
have no doubts that in the next 3-5
years we are going to see tons of
applications will be blooming using a
tiny mail for all kind of things I think
doing like we have people here from from
Europe who use machine learning for
industrial IG doing some predictive
maintenance for the motors for example
so this is just an example and also show
more examples in any minute so first
example I'm going to share with you and
by the way also be some more more
technology scanning will you call the
kind of trivial technologies that's
ultra-low power sensors new memories 3G
Steichen how do you put things together
the energy scavenging extremely
low-power areas I mean this will all
help to make this field developing
faster and and bigger and grow any
bigger
moving on to examples how examples first
one this is my baby so my team's baby we
develop extremely low-power vision
sensor so typically the way you do
computer vision today and some people in
the audience know this you take an image
to use a camera taking image a
high-resolution image 728 an 80 or even
high-resolution image and then you
transmit this image to the edge device
or out device and you do processing
there so the sense of takes power
transmission takes power processing
takes power and that becomes kind of a
big again hundreds of millions type of
power consumption so what we do in this
case again we look at the whole system
holistically we design the architecture
shown there on on the right so this is a
dedicated processor that has some
dedicated Hardware block to accelerate
machine learning computer vision there
we have extremely low-power dedicated
ASIC a low-power CPU have low power
memory we have also power manage
you need their which is not shown this
allows us to do innovations that the
processor level we have special design
for the sensor this sensor consumes as
much power as accelerometer and in Jireh
in f1 today so it's kind of insane the
whole thing is less power at what
accelerometers and gyros use which kind
of invisible on on the phone and as a
result we if you have like less than 1
million would kind of again qualify to
be tiny male power for the whole
end-to-end system it's extremely low
again the output of this device we are
not sending images so the output of this
device is metadata I can show you an
example here so the whole the whole
device by the way is shown here it's
like about few millimeters by few
millimeters I have it here in my pocket
so it's like like about this grain of
rice type of size type of device and the
functionality for example one of them in
terms of privacy so this one runs a face
detection model you see the blue light
here detects my face when I look at the
fake yeah so now it's I'm looking sink
for face detection the mirror just to
see where the faces but the point here
your onion computer vision algorithms in
this battery-operated device at high
frame rates less than 1 milli watt of
power we are not sending images to the
data all detection all classification
everything happens in this in this very
tiny device two by two and now I'll show
some some kind of examples where it can
be used so it can be used in many
different applications you can do those
are real images from the device which we
don't transmit this is just for
demonstration purposes
human detection then we do face
detection you can train models just like
standard machine Lorien type of
techniques to do logo detection you can
do some detection for retail like shelf
status customer engagements how much
time customers spend in front of the
shelf in supermarkets you can build a
lot of use cases tablet on this you can
do a gesture type of detection all at
this extremely low power
yes everything happens in this small
form-factor the question was live around
a machine learning at this this small
device yes everything happens there the
output is just metadata which is the
digested resolved there so this is to
show how we use tiny mail instead of
remember the picture showed the
beginning of the physical world analog
world and we bring all of this to the
edge and video all this analytics at the
edge so next yeah this is important its
language it's at okay okay and as I said
earlier it's a term which we are still
defining accurately studies will come
probably in sometime soon okay there are
no standards at this point just like
activity there are no standards in that
it's a common approach but is it owned
by anybody it's not owned by Qualcomm no
it's not but going for oh yeah yeah
right it's a group of people if you're
agreeing right do things in the same way
at this point it's a community of people
okay
ecosystem of people yeah who would like
to develop these technologies together
people doing sensors people didn't
processors people didn't software people
algorithms people doing applications all
coming together and building this tiny
ml community so it's a relatively open
set of information right that you can
get about how to do this it's not relied
if it's very open this is critical it's
but it's by design
because we believe that the tiny male PI
is going to be so big you'll be yeah
enough slices for everyone who
contributes to it you make you make it
happen no side was there okay again it's
an open community for people who want to
collaborate partner and accelerate this
community globally
okay in all across different industries
across different technologies it's okay
but the key there's a short earlier is
really this boundary between the
physical world and yeah and because we
are not doing routers this type of thing
it's really and people also show some
examples is how do we do much
learning machine intelligence at the at
the sensor level at the physical world
level sure but I guess the reason that
I'm asking this question is because way
back in like 3G you know Qualcomm was a
key developer of CDMA technologies and
that was something that led to lots of
licensing for Qualcomm but tiny ml is a
different kind of thing it's a different
thing in a way that we have silicon
providers like us providing solutions to
okay - people are software developers
like what Peters going to be talking
about our development solution for this
and these solutions are all open source
you can go to the github sand and get
the court codes to be able there and the
energy differentiation comes mostly from
the end-users people for users to solve
real problems also so they tried ml the
toolbox of all these things to solve
their the big problems yeah I think if
you wanted to use an analogy with CDMA I
think we're still at the stage where
we're trying to persuade everyone that
people would like to have cell phones
rather than competing are like the best
way to do it okay we're like evangelical
mode right right that's a very good
point yeah and the very early stage I
think the stand-ups and everything will
come later
okay so we'll come back when we're all
three hawking of the panel we'll come
back and do this but you know what did
you kind of get that off yeah okay so I
would like to switch gears because I
think Pete needs to present his stuff to
you soon
switch gears to til next modality which
is audio obviously what is important I
mean vision is about 87% of human
perception all your is about 10% so tiny
male is really also good for always-on
voice here I'm showing two companies
obviously with their permission both of
them are startups
both of them in the Southern California
area city and what they do they use very
small neural nets about full ears and
they develop very efficient ASIC I mean
this is the ASIC they use by two
millimeter square or something and what
this allows them to do this
do 64 classes of keyword detection
extremely low power in this generation
is the first generation of silicon
hundred forty microwatts so that's kind
of quite impressive what it can do it
and the approach they they've chosen is
to use this short small networks and is
actually what works quite fine with
their their own training tools so the
other approach is from Robin I'll start
up a on devices so they look at this
also holistically they do audio
processing at all levels the data
preparation training and then they do
RTL design this is design company for
their own chip and you can see their
power consumption is about hundred micro
was about the same rate ranged than the
previous one and they estimate I show
the market numbers earlier that in a
couple of years and few years is going
to be about a billion devices deploying
this type technology so again always
important that I name there was a really
good application for this one moving on
to the next modalities talking about
sensors everyone knows borscht borscht
is number one sensor company in the
world today
so they're shipping or billions of
sensors to to their consumers so this is
the presentation from the a CEO last
week was also with the permission
obviously so they've been talking about
what was been happening the sensors from
the software perspective so the first
wave was just to to be able to use
software for sensors the second way it
was to do more fusion and now they're
talking about the third wave and the
third way they identify from the sensor
side now is H AI and sensor boards and
what they emphasize in here is that
software is becoming with intelligent
enabling AI inside the center itself
again they talking about tiny ml coming
not only from the software side from the
processor side but also from the sensor
side so and having companies like
borscht with this massive shipment will
again help to deploy this tiny male at
massive scale at this level as well and
they show a couple of interest in
example one example is use temperature
pressure humidity
and by the way these devices diaper is
probably yes Anoka said yes and what
they interested is the state of this
device is it dry wet dirty so again you
can use some tiny mail there to be able
to do this kind of things
another example is little bit more
sophisticated if you get more sense of
data like temperature grass quality
vision for human presence you can use a
step of device to model forest climate
models to do some risk management for
for fires and an other type of
applications like unified detection and
so on but again the point and two points
are trying to I'm trying to make here
one is again you can use tiny mail for
all kind of different sensory modalities
and second having this type of huge
momentum from the sensor company is
easily going to accelerate tiny mail
coming coming to the market in next few
years and the last example I am going to
use is from this company it's also
startup this is a spin-off from in tow
and sends a mail they showed a tiny mail
Meetup it is this Monday you have four
monthly meetups if you are interested
I'll show you some information so what
they do they develop software tools to
be able to train models to use
accelerometers and gyros you see
accelerometers in gyrus I new units
attached to their to the motor or any
kind of IOT device and then you can
train models to find some abnormalities
and you can use it abnormalities to
whatever you want to do there so so
again tiny mail type of applications
because in this case in the past people
use massive inertia type of units they
cost thousands of dollars and now thanks
to memes this type of devices cost a
couple of dollars and low-power and you
can use these devices in big volumes
yeah we probably not going to have time
to show all tiny in our examples but I
just wanted to give you a flavor how you
can use tiny mail for vision for audio
for chemical sensing for IMU sensing and
tons of applications and it is going to
share more to sum up
I started with three questions the first
question is what is tiny mail given tiny
mail is machine learning technologies
and approaches at the very edge between
the physical world analog world and any
physical and the digital world and it
has to be done it
Emilia what all this type of power
that's how we define it why because
there are a lot of analytical
capabilities and delicate abilities at
this level and a lot of financial
opportunities there how you need your
design your system sadistically system
software and hardware core design and
when I think hopefully I show you that
this list of technologies are happening
now couple of announcements before I
turn maternity suite
I think PD and I and a group of us we
organize now second any assignment is
going to be here in a Bay Area
I think there are still few spots
available but not too many so if you're
interested please go to the website and
you can get all this information there
so those are the companies who sign up
to support this year you see very very
impressive list of so these companies
are sponsoring the conference or they're
sponsoring the whole tiny amount move at
this point formally speaking it's the
conference ok informally speaking their
members ok movement community and
talking about companies those of the
companies who attended the first summit
in in March was about 90 companies you
can you see all these names
this is participant so he very very
diverse community people from from from
the whole spectrum basically from like
applied material we just pull guys all
the way to software companies and big
small company Stanford was there too so
we here we have Boris on the committee
as you know and as I say the community
is growing rapidly so we are over
thousand people now it's again open open
community and online we have two tools
we're doing meetups in in the Bay Area
here monthly typically about hungry
class people and then our tiny mile in
Lincoln Community it's about 600 people
so if you're interested join us and
a lot of discussions around around tiny
ml and that's it I guess that's kind of
that came from one of the engineers okay
thank you
right so let me kind of change the
slides over to Pete slides and while
we're doing that how do I get out of
this show that makes sense and then
start this show so Evgeny if somebody
wants to join the tiny ml movement yeah
what do they do
just join now who did they talk to you
yeah I mean we have a non-profit
organization okay
that was formerly entity it's about tiny
male foundation and there are people who
who manage this the contact is dead it's
on the website I mean the easiest is to
remember is to go to the website tiny my
ultimate orgy and there are people who
help them do this thing okay great
yeah no this is a great start why don't
you pick it up Pete Pete worden is a
research engineer at Google he's the
technical lead of the tensorflow
mobile and embedded team and before
joining Google he was with jetpack from
2011 until it was acquired I guess by
Google yeah in 2014 and jetpack actually
analyzed photo data from Instagram to
create in-depth guides more than 5,000
cities worldwide and before that he has
experience as a serial entrepreneur he
was also with Apple for a while was a
senior engineer so great
Pete Pete worden thanks very much for
coming and talking with us and giving us
some use cases for tiny ml No thank you
and thank you very Annie
so the question we had was Oh
actually get involved in tiny amount
well I'm going to be talking about an
open-source framework that you can just
download and you can actually just buy
an Arduino for about 30 bucks and then
just use the Arduino IDE
just start running all of the examples
that I'm going to be showing you so I
wanted to kind of get into the sort of
the concrete way that you can actually
start playing with and using and
building product around tiny ml right
now so just to kind of recap what we're
aiming at are these devices that have
incredibly small amounts of memory you
know we're down to like the tens of
kilobytes of RAM and flash so we have
all of these like kind of constraints we
have to deal with when we're writing
software for these the good news though
is over 250 billion of these out there
in the world already there's 40 billion
being sold every year and that number is
going by 20 percent every year as well
and their average price hovers around 50
cents and you can even get some that are
down to as low as 3 cents each so you
can buy microcontrollers there please
pretty much cheaper than like you know a
resistor or a capacitor which is you
know kind of mind-blowing and I was
being asked as well like ok where are
these we don't see them so where do
these exist
you have probably tens or even maybe
hundreds of these in your car they're in
your washing machine they're in your
toaster they're in the toys your kids
have they're in every medical device
they're in your credit cards almost
anything that is manufactured and has
any kind of electrical component it's
gonna have a microcontroller in it now
because they're way cheaper than even
just kind of like the old way of wiring
sort of wires together to make things
happen it's way easier to just use
software
to build your systems now
so what tensorflow light four
microcontrollers actually does is it
takes tensorflow this very you know
powerful system for training machine
learning models and it figures out how
to help you get those kinds of models
down into this like tens of kilobytes
environment so we already had tens flow
light from my for mobile devices and
that was giving you you know you could
fit your code into maybe hundreds of
kilobytes but in order to actually fit
this into the kind of environments that
we needed to run in embedded systems we
had to create our own interpreter and do
a whole bunch of stuff around the
software engineering to avoid things
like even relying on there being any
kind of operating system you can't
allocate memory
you can't expect that there's going to
be any kind of printf or any way of you
know sort of you know in dealing with
strings or even any of the basic
standard c library stuff so we had you
know it's a bit like kind of building a
cathedral out of matchstick so we had to
kind of figure out how to do all of the
machine learning stuff we needed to do
without any of the tools that were used
to having so we could actually shrink
things down into like a 20 kilobyte
footprint as i mentioned the good news
is that you can actually grab this right
now you can get a board for just sort of
you know $15 $30 and actually start
running all of the examples I'm going to
be showing you and you can get these
boards from a whole variety of different
you know providers because it's an open
source project you don't have to be tied
to any particular sort of hardware you
can actually you know run this code with
most of the major embedded systems
so I've been talking a lot about you
know machine learning in the abstract
but what does this mean in practice what
can you actually do right now I actually
had a magic wand I was going to show you
that I thought was very appropriate for
Halloween but unfortunately I left it at
my desk so you'll just have to imagine
it but that was actually a great example
of using gesture recognition using an
accelerometer and you can actually
download that example right now from as
part of the tensorflow
arduino library and also the library for
all of these other boards that we're
talking about you can also do simple
speech recognition i was actually first
attracted to this whole world when I
when I joined Google back in 2014 and I
was talking to the speech team and I
found that they had a 14 kilobyte model
your network model that they were using
to recognize okay Google on people's
phones so that was really kind of the
inspiration but for me to start looking
into this was wow if you can do so much
with such a small model for speech what
else can we do with this so we do have a
speech recognition example that you can
train yourself we also have an
open-source example of doing person
detection kind of like what if Gani was
showing where it's actually possible to
have a device wake up when there's
somebody around which is one of the most
common use cases that we actually get
asked for and as of again II was saying
as well predictive maintenance is a
really important area we all know we can
hear when our car is starting to have a
problem it turns out that your networks
can be trained to kind of spot those
kind of anomalies too and can be really
really useful surprisingly to me I
discovered that it's actually really
hard to
plug something in and a factory having
sensors that appeal and stick to do this
kind of predictive maintenance is really
really important even though
theoretically you might have power it
can cost thousands of dollars and be
extremely disruptive trying to access
power so having something that's able to
run on a battery and just kind of be
stuck on the side of a machine to tell
when it's about to go wrong turns out to
be incredibly useful talking about
speech recognition I kind of wanted to
give you some you know rough laws of
thumb for how much work is involved in
running these models so we have our
example speech detection model it's got
about 20,000 parameters in it and
they're stored as 8-bit so that works
out to be about a twenty kilobyte model
and it requires about 7 million
arithmetic ops per second so if you
think about a microcontroller that might
be running at you know 50 megahertz or
something like that as long as you can
do an arithmetic op in like two or three
cycles you've got room to spare to
actually run this model even like an
imperative lis kind of low horsepower
chip person detection on the other hand
is a bit beefier it requires 250
kilobytes of space so you know this is
over 200,000 parameters and it needs
about 60 million arithmetic ops so this
is gonna take either a processor that
has a bit more oomph if you want to do
it in kind of under a second or it's
going to take a couple of seconds to do
each inference but you know there's lots
of applications where being able to sort
of you know detect a person every couple
of seconds isn't actually a severe
constraint the gesture recognition
example is again about a twenty kilobyte
model I don't have the exact number
with meta cops but it's about the same
as the sort of the voice recognition
stuff so hopefully that's given you some
like concrete examples to think about
this stuff and you know if you grab the
code and download it you can actually
dig through it and play with it yourself
and really kind of get a feel for how
well this stuff works so where are we
going after this
I mean if Kenny has talked about a lot
of this already but in some of the you
know concrete ways forward I think we're
gonna see voice interfaces in almost
anything that people want to interact
with you know once you have the
possibility of being able to do a good
voice interface for $0.50 and it will
run for a year on a coin battery you're
going to end up having voice interfaces
for placing switches and buttons in
almost any consumer item and especially
if you think about devices being able to
combine audio and video so voice
interfaces that know when you're looking
at the object so if you have 20 devices
around your house you don't have to have
a special keyword for each one so that's
my guess for where the biggest immediate
growth is going to be is like this stuff
is starting to become possible now and
we've already seen that voice interfaces
are actually pretty popular with people
so if we can get them in more places
we're just waiting really on the you
know the hardware to be available for
this to happen
longer term there's going to be a
massive amount of adoption of ml for all
of these cases where the physical world
needs to interact with the digital world
so almost any embedded systems worldwide
these hundreds of billions of devices
which I think are going to grow into
trillions of devices are all going to be
using these and
kind of like where these questions were
coming about like what is tiny amount
again from all of these different
communities you know I hadn't had any
experience doing embedded development
before I dived into this a few years ago
so I've had to kind of get myself up to
speed on what embedded developers
already know but most embedded
developers don't know any machine
learning so both communities are having
to kind of join together and then
there's a whole hardware community as
well who you know so really what we look
at is the way that machine learning as a
field has grown by being very very open
and by sharing models and by having open
source frameworks right from the start
and we're hoping that we can follow the
same kind of model for the tiny ml
community where all of these people who
have the different art pieces of the
puzzle are able to come together and
actually talk openly and actually help
you know drive this field forward and
help kind of achieve the promise that we
are think all see in here so I'm hoping
that you know some of you may actually
be interested in this and will get
involved and have ideas and have
problems that can be solved and I'll be
looking forward to the discussion and
talking to you afterwards it's great
Thank You Pete so why don't you and then
step closer to the middle and let me
stay over all yeah so first of all as a
technical kind of initiative I think
this is great but what do you have to
tell the business people to make this
work - if you've got somebody who says
ok I'm developing something at X company
and we must own everything we must keep
it all quiet
stay away I mean I would say sure that's
fine I mean you're welcome to make it's
open-source software we were super Co to
have people take it and and build things
you know we think that you'll get more
out of it if you're involved in the
community mm-hmm but I you know I'm
quite happy to be in kind of transmitted
only mode and you know what we really
are looking for is anything that can
help people build these things I think
is you know it's gonna have a big
positive impact so even if people aren't
able to contribute back by discussions
if they're actually able to build cool
stuff using this we're happy so an
open-source software community and in
that regard you're running into all this
kind of problems these days where you
know people are trying to say you've got
export control because this is you know
has military applications how do you
deal with those international problems I
noticed that the list of companies that
Guinea had listed up there as people has
companies from just about everywhere the
participants are involved you know I saw
Huawei up there I saw in XP from Europe
up there on this tee from Europe up
there I saw a bunch of American
companies up there how do you do this I
think we're dealing with technology
technology has a longer longer-term role
or run away compared to the politics
because politics is back and forth I
think we are developed in the platform
that people can can use ok well but yeah
that's ok no this is great but this is
really important to think that this can
be done in this kind of a you know
situation where you've got countries
that are kind of maybe decoupling from
each other yeah
it applies to all technologists it's not
just tightening now today yeah right
right ok ok great and I think to your
earlier questions on the only business
of tiny Mail I mean the way I think
about this
the tiny ml is a tool that we offer to
the to their different verticals for
people to sell to solve problems and as
a tool to makers make money software
people will be making money hard way
people will be making money algorithm
people who train these things but on top
of this people who solve problems we've
been making money too and hopefully this
money will also go back to this
community through different business
models like even you share in type of
models and so on I mean the key is
really to create this value and how the
weight is going to be shared it will be
shared one way the other yeah it may be
disproportional but that's the nature of
business but definitely everyone who has
leading-edge technologies are going to
going to benefit from this ok so let's
open the floor to questions
go ahead I saw your hand first let's not
about 7 million opps for the audio
inference and something like is that is
the tensorflow light giving you these
numbers or you calculate them some other
way so there are ways to yeah I was
actually able to get these through
tensorflow light but it's also possible
to just do pen and paper calculations is
how most of these models I think I used
one of our internal scripts actually but
I've also four other ones in the past
I've just you know especially small
models you know for only a tens of
thousands of parameters you can usually
just kind of write on the back of an
envelope and for a specific target like
let's say an Arduino does the platform
tell you what the limit is for that
specific hardware or it tells you what
the limits are for memory for the number
of calculations it's basically means to
even have to wait longer for the result
like the ladies just the Empowered to
come yeah so it'll still be able to run
it just might take like six seconds
to produce a result rather than two
seconds or whatever but you know
depending on the speed at the processor
yeah yeah do you have any projects
you're thinking about yes oh but yeah
there's a bunch of other ideas yeah yeah
techniques you're doing sort of a
operating point ones that you're using
to get done of the 20k parameters why
don't one watt system event in that same
approach well what you're trading off is
accuracy so for most like one watt
systems they don't you know usually
they're either plugged in or plugged in
every night so shaving off a you know a
bit of energy usage for a drop in
accuracy is often not the right
trade-off for them we do you know use
those same techniques to help people for
example ship mobile apps that are
smaller because that's a big deal like
you've got like hundred megabyte limits
on some app stores and things so people
can't afford to have like 20 megabytes
they can only have like 500k or
something so we do use the same
techniques but the the constraints and
the trade-offs different in the
different spaces yeah exactly it's as
like what we tend to do is like you you
we being who we being I think the
broader ml community but also just when
we're talking about specifically when
we're creating examples and sample code
kind of demos what we'll usually try and
do is get a model that's as accurate as
possible and don't you know down the
size and then once you've got to that
point you can then use a bunch of
techniques to do trade-offs to kind of
make it smaller but drop the accuracy a
bit and like I'll make it a bit faster
but the
to see a little bit more but hopefully
you're still above like kind of the
operating point of the accuracy you need
so it's like this race to kind of get as
much accuracy as you can and then you
can kind of sell some of it accuracy for
other properties you want to want to hit
for you engineering okay this is great
for technical work that people can agree
to cooperate on and you know in terms of
somebody who's trying to develop a
system if they're in a big company or if
they're in a startup company so yes we
should use tiny ml they say that back to
the company what does the company say I
think it's all water owned it yeah no I
think it's all application specific it
is quite a bit of know-how an idea that
is being generated when you apply
knowledge like that's a flow yeah why it
opens for micro mm-hmm to solve a
specific problem that's kind of where
you have quite a bit of firm it and I
think the key thing is that if you're
the company what you are really supposed
to be good at is knowing what your
customers need and so you're going to be
able to build a better model than
anybody else because you know what the
requirements are better than anybody
else and you can serve the customers
better than you yeah okay and how do you
how do you keep there from being so many
different flavors of tiny ml that it
kind of loses its cohesiveness well I
think ideally would like to be on a
platform like like one platform for
example tensorflow and you have hardware
devices like arm type of devices time
devices or explain that devices using
this as a framework to run tiny mail on
this type of devices yeah okay are you
looking at any kind of a model in the
past as having been a really
particularly good model for the
development community kind of follow
like units or you know some of the the
wireless technology you know I mentioned
CDMA earlier but I'm coming at this from
the outside from a non technical aspect
right and so I think it's really
important for the
business community to understand how the
technology community can make this
happen well I would I would think about
Android yes an example that's no
technology okay that enables a lot of
different companies to produce you know
that own products like it's this
enabling technology yeah yeah and really
I think that that's something that
Google really helped to deliver and
Google saw that the bigger openness of
Android was a benefit to Google without
taking over what other people are trying
to hold is their own proprietary work
okay okay which communication
technologies can you also company I
think they again very specifically
application like for example we do for
some customer service on some of them
Bluetooth type of technologies some of
them by fighter for technologies some of
them use several to eat a perfect
knowledge five five G in the future I
think 5g is going to have a lot of
promise for for for this type of
connected devices I think initially it's
probably going to be more like a
standalone technologist when you put
them together system eventually there
may be some co-opt emulation happening
at the connectivity of as well and this
is simply because this tiny ml machine
systems are becoming so efficient so you
can get your inference done it's very
low energy so but the other question is
even like these few bits of information
how do you transmit it transmit takes
more energy than the inference because
this is the tiny me I was actually
getting very very good and then people
are doing some small things you do batch
and you send your data once they for
some applications instead of doing it
every second but I think it would be
some innovations and we see some
startups in this space to in the
low-power area type of technologies as
well and one way to think about it is
you can almost see ml as this really
good data compression technique where
instead of sending like war video
streams from some like camera that's
looking at the subway tracks and then
trying to make sense of them on the
other end like you just have something
that said like only ever transmits when
there's a person on the subway tracks
and that suddenly turns as instead of
sending gigabytes or terabytes you're
sending one bit effectively like maybe
once every few months exactly yeah in
the kilobytes
what's this diction depends on range
defensely duty cycle but subject mode is
in this media what type of range anyway
and and you really the way I think about
it is duty cycling if we can make it so
that even if it takes like 500
milliwatts for like 10 seconds to send
something if you only have to do that
once a month rather than like
continuously then okay might look like
for tiny ml many trolls we know that
many companies I keep in this field is
you start up the big companies they fire
them but I think another thing is also
there are major techniques that they are
sort of like there is a
cross-pollination happen in between the
tiny male world and the bigger male
world like some techniques like
compression and quantization those
things they came from the edge type of
devices that we use a tiny amount to but
there's also some fundamental IPS I said
earlier because we are very concentrated
what we can do in the tiny ml so that
means the challenge always means an
opportunity and whoever solves this
challenge gets gets a solution and it
can be patentable so are some some some
a tiny male specific IP as well but then
you don't see any kind of patent Wars
you know on the horizon yes go ahead
I'm coming from it from a non technical
standpoint but you said that tiny amount
reduces the privacy concerns that you
have with an agile cloud I was wondering
if he could walk us through that
presumably all the analytics is being
done on device but who owns that data
and how does it mitigate privacy
concerns and the second question is in
China we've seen an increasing sort of
verification of open source so far away
has now among and you have I do with the
Apollo open source a what's the tiny ml
community like overseas particularly in
Asia and is there a risk of you know
increasing decoupling you know British
putnams yeah on the first question if I
said is by design physically tiny mail
type of devices our privacy I can give
you a couple of examples like for
example the Crimea show there you can
put this type of devices in a bedroom
bathroom
elder elder a care facility because all
it does it says I see people in off a
hotel room if there is a fire in the
hotel it would know that this room has
two occupants and the rest of the hotel
is empty so then the the firefighters
will go to this room but we are not
sending daily just like it sends
metadata there so I think the metadata
is really key for the privacy and
against by design and on the second
question the tiny Markham unity in China
there are a lot of players there I think
it's probably not as communities here in
fact we've been thinking about doing
that I named ml also so like cymet are
there as well it's probably going to
happen that next year but offices are
are as you say it very china specific
aspects there as well how how you do
this things there and the key thing for
me for privacy is that even though you
have like a camera sensor the data never
leaves the device like the recording the
image data the audio data never leaves
the device and actually gets kind of
thrown away after each frame so there
that really mitigates the risk of like
you're not sending it anywhere it's
staying local and one of the things I've
actually been proposing that we've been
talking about in the
some of the tiny mail sort of community
meetings is can we come up with a
standard that actually enforces that
inability to record data at the hardware
level so we can actually make sure that
all you get out is the output of running
a model on that data
so like afghani said the metadata like
yes there's a person here no there isn't
a person here and that even if there's a
malicious person who's trying to kind of
you know subvert some of these devices
they actually can't get through to the
hardware that's actually got the war
input signal because yeah I think this
is you know this is one of the things
I'm excited about this and I think this
is really important this area as it
gives us this chance to have much more
control over what's happening with data
and you know I've I've on the second
question you know I've been over to
Beijing there's been a fantastic you
know kind of response to when we did a
open community meeting around tensorflow
lie and microcontrollers there's a lot
of you know companies out there doing
fantastic stuff so you know I see a very
bright future for this sort of tiny
Emmaus stuff in Asia in general and you
know China in particular so how do you
see the tiny ml kind of community
developing will it be essentially a
technical community that is then
certifying something as being compliant
with tiny ml or using tiny ml as sort of
the tools of techniques of tiny ml but
yet you know I can see how you know how
do you how do you how do you ensure that
people aren't taking data that would
people would not want to have taken so I
think there's two questions that I mean
one of them is
at least yes I mean one of them is like
what we say you know honestly I see the
tiny amount community at the moment as
like somebody years ago said something
to me along the lines of the only way
things get ever get done in Silicon
Valley is when you've got a conspiracy
of engineers and you know right now it
feels like we're in this conspiracy of
engineers phase where were all at these
different companies and we want to go to
our management and say hey look here's
this cool prototype here's this cool
thing you know there's now possible that
was not possible before let's do
something with this and so I think that
you know if we can get to that stage
then that is gonna kind of like you know
that knowledge is gonna percolate
through the company and it's gonna be
you know through our different companies
and it's gonna sort of become a thing
now in terms of how we ensure that these
things aren't misused I mean that's
where having standards is actually
helpful and having something that can be
audited to make sure that it is actually
secure and the same way that we approach
kind of you know security in general if
we can come together and have some thing
that people can you know point to and
say look this has been checked we have
done everything we can to make sure that
this can't be used as a recording device
mm-hmm I think that that will be really
important okay the beginning of a long
journey yeah I think right now it's
deeply technical it's by design again
that's what you wanted to be in the
first step to make sure people speak the
same language and I understand each
other and then then I think maybe the
dynamics of a you know a very positive
technical community that would say look
this is what you're going to give up if
you if you do get into this kind of
recording or whatever right okay
so you dimension at using Arduino board
and I don't know so many flavors try to
what is your vision on now how the
company can differentiate themselves is
there going to be a large acceleration I
think there's all sorts of I mean the
great news is that there's lots of
problems with the whole process so you
know you can differentiate on usability
you know which Arduino is really good at
you could differentiate on Arduino found
out Arduino is the most popular hobbyist
and maker microcontroller okay so it's
this very open community I think they
have tens of millions of developers who
actually using Arduino to build all
sorts of you know different
microcontrollers occupancy report
machine specific so what is the
potential for using the tiny ml for mass
surveillance right the police put out an
all-points bulletin for Charlie Chan so
they send out all these devices their
model for recognizing Charlie Chan and
bingo they've got it because they got
all those devices up there looking for
Charlie Chan so I think in this case I
think the you know damn well it's better
if it it it can be put anywhere and it's
always on at the same time it may not
have enough horsepower to be able to
detect across on a kilometer away or a
mile away because and I'm guessing that
you would also say is that until you
have a standard developed that's really
not going to be a question about the
tiny ml community it is going to be
involved in deploying real commercial
solutions using pioneer
we have some real examples that come
from from real people real serious we've
been talking to city offices of many
cities here in California and some use
cases they brought related to this for
example if you deploy this type of
devices in the park where people
obviously concern about privacy then you
can see some suspicious behavior like if
all sudden people start to run then
something's going on there right and
then you can send in the police they're
all kind of more powerful cameras
they're all people dump garbage in some
places and you want to make sure that
it's not happening again I think what
makes tiny mail cool is you have a
combination of privacy because people
are sensitive to privacy for reason and
kind of a inability to have this massive
deployment and collect this data but at
the same time again there are some
trade-offs because the horsepower may
not be I mean a resolution for example
of cameras may not be enough to do to
get this high-resolution images from
from afar and the limitation on
horsepower is because you want to be
able to deliver so many different
devices right we want to have a scale
right and if you're trying to scale with
too high horsepower then basically it
slows it down too much I mean from this
perspective tiny ml is complementary to
other solutions there is tiny ml that is
h ml that is the cloud email and all of
this will be kind of working working
together to solve specific problems
looking forward straight of battery
capacity and processing powers over the
artificial ones so where do you see this
trend going well I mean we if you look
at the trend of battery increases it's
it's not been like you know sort of the
the web scale or like all of these other
you know yeah exactly so that's that's
the nice thing is that we're able to get
more processing and more memory out of
the same amount of energy solution to a
short come from so I think the key
constraint is the lack of energy and
we're always gonna want to go kind of
smaller and cheaper and lower power for
these devices so I foresee for the rest
of my career at least like knock on wood
there's gonna be there's going to be
this kind of frontier of things getting
smaller and cheaper you know down to
like dust motes sized you know things
that can be scattered anywhere that can
actually do significant amounts of
sensor processing so I really see the
kind of things where there are sort of
millimeters by millimeters at the moment
as being actually quite large and kind
of only the first wave of being able to
get this kind of ubiquitous ambient
computing in all of our material things
so I think that there's going to
continue to be a need for going smaller
and going cheaper I think for me just to
follow and I think the key matrix here
is useful information per energy right I
mean today we maybe we can get as much
useful information because we're energy
limited in many cases so yes we becoming
more and more hungry for more
you really need to get this kind of down
to the to the data level and that's
that's that's what there are some
discussions there I think I'm not sure
there is a formal group their way or any
piece either it's not there's not really
any formal group there has been a lot of
discussion especially things like
anomaly detection if you want to be able
to like slap a sense on the side of a
machine and not have to do a bunch of
setup you sort of need the sensor to
figure out what's normal you know maybe
the first hour of operation it takes and
decides okay this is normal and then
anything that's a significant deviation
from that it kind of you know sends a
radio distress signal but that doesn't
necessarily require full learning
exactly so there's this really
interesting spectrum all the way from
just kind of you know some very sort of
simple kind of tweaking of the results
depending on circumstances all the way
through to kind of fall back propagation
and retraining yeah would it be would it
be too much to say that basically what
you're doing is you're using the
physical constraints of energy and
latency as limits that would help
preserve privacy and that you're
creating a community at this stage when
those physical limits really do
constrain how much information you can
send out in order to solve the later
problems that will occur as you have
more ability to deal with you know
energy you know and more more advanced
technologies you're creating the
community now to solve the m/l the tiny
ml using tiny ml to solve these privacy
problems or to have a route forward to
solve a non-metal data so that that's
that's a really good question and there
are or some existing libraries like
microsoft's ll-like sensi ml is using a
lot more traditional techniques what has
been really interesting has been like
the speech team and like a lot of the
other product teams that we've worked
with who've gone through a lot of
evaluations of different approaches most
of them have ended up using kind of the
you know the deep learning style neural
networks is kind of their their standard
tool now I'm not gonna say that they're
you know there isn't the I'm sure
there's space for like you know random
forests and all this sort of stuff
there's so many problems to solve but
right now there just seems to be this
very rich reign in kind of just applying
a standard template to a lot of
different problems and it also
simplifies a lot of the like integration
work and things like that so I I'm
definitely a fan of all those other
approaches but right now we're getting
big payoffs from just kind of and just
to illustrate this point you may know
years ago DARPA had a challenge they
call it n0 program so what they wanted
to do is can you develop a system that
can do sound recognition like for
example glass breakage versus truck type
of thing at nano what
power and they put together a team smart
University people around and being able
if I remember the number
couple hundred nano words and what they
use they use a render for a start of
classifier in hardware and the point is
it depends really what you're trying to
accomplish
it's it's a system different if you want
to do very low energy glass breakage
type of detector or drug detector you
can just trade it specifically for the
thing and they're classical models work
work work dice if you want to do
something flexible to be able to detect
classes of objects and probably Chanel's
are more powerful but they require more
on a memory style on the processor side
so that it becomes a system trade often
and what is good enough I think we there
was a question earlier what is what is
good enough because some of the systems
the accuracy can be 90% and it's perfect
because you can put three or four this
type of devices and do the redundancy
type of things you can easily bring up
your accuracy quite right maybe just
good enough so it's really I mean for
tiny male the system approach is really
important for the from the application
perspective radios like what kind of
radius use what is duty cycle and then
that's also all important questions but
I do believe that there is like pizza
there is a cosy the coexistence of this
more modern approaches neural based type
of approaches and I think they're the
more traditional classifiers we all will
have applications of my own yeah one
more question
back in the back
[Music]
in between the robustness and the size
of the model I tend to think that
simpler the models the easier it is to
attack I have in mind the example of an
autonomous car that we're that he's
singing about and assigned and if you
change so slightly the imagine is saying
it could mix classify this sign
imagine a stop sign on you you put a
sticker on it and then suddenly it sees
a speed limit that would be terrible in
that case so I wonder if you have a
smaller model does it does it have an
impact on the robustness and like one of
my favorite examples of this was I
mentioned the yes-no detector I had that
at a at a show a few months ago and a
couple of students came over and they
spent like half an hour like playing
with it and they finally discovered that
if instead of saying yes you hissed at
it it would recognize it would think
that you were saying yes yes they were
very excited and you know that's a great
example but really also did this a
question like how do you train your
model it is but it's also a whole system
design question of you don't want to
have kind of these single points of
failure around these sort of you know
you need to design a whole system that's
actually going to be robust because even
without deliberate malicious attacks
you're gonna get you know incorrect
predictions and mistakes and you know
just like you do kind of with humans and
if you design a system so that you can
have one thing like that but has really
bad consequences with know like checks
and balances then you've designed a
really bad system so that's I think I
think I feel like there's a whole field
around that should emerge around
building systems
to deal with kind of unreliable inputs
and still being able to make the whole
system actually have a level of
robustness that you need so yeah I mean
I think it's I think you're exactly
right there's a you know especially
these small models they aren't hard to
fool so we need to really think about
how we how we work around that okay I
think that we've run out of time but
we've got some refreshments outside we
can continue our discussions in a more
informal context there are no bad
questions thanks everybody and thanks so
much for your presentation today
[Applause]